Hi and welcome to Udacity's Data
Analyst Nanodegree Program.
I'm Caroline Buckey.
And before I joined Udacity, I did a
combination of software engineering and
machine learning.
Now, there's more data in the world
today than there ever has been,
and it's constantly growing.
>From sources like transaction records,
sensor data,
even people taking photos or
videos on their cell phones,
we're collecting more than 2.5
quintillion bytes of data every day.
Because of this, data analysts
have never been in higher demand.
By completing this Nanodegree program,
you'll have the qualifications you need
to either start or
advance your career as a data analyst.
And you'll build a portfolio
of projects to prove it.
To start out, you'll use statistics
to analyze the Stroop effect,
a classic result in
experimental psychology.
Then you'll go through the entire
data analysis process,
starting by posing a question and
finishing by sharing your findings.
Then you'll hone in on your data
wrangling skills by cleaning
OpenStreetMap data for
a part of the world you care about.
Next you'll use exploratory data
analysis techniques to build intuition
about a data set by exploring
both individual variables and
how those variables interact.
You'll also use machine learning and
natural language processing to uncover
fraud in the infamous Enron scandal.
You'll create an effective data
visualization that will tell an engaging
and unforgettable story for
your audience.
And finally you'll analyze an A/B test
that Udacity ran, recommend whether or
not to launch the change, and
propose your own follow-up experiment.
>> Building these
projects won't be easy.
We're going to challenge you so
that you're prepared to solve tough
problems and think independently.
To rise to that challenge, you'll need
to keep up with your learning schedule
and engage with your
Nanodegree community.
Your fellow students are here to help
you untangle the trickiest puzzles,
get over the biggest hurdles, and
encourage you through all of it.
And when they need help,
you'll do the same for them.
The Udacity team will be here
too to deepen your learning,
offer project feedback, and
help you develop professionally.
By leveraging the support systems and
working consistently, you can prepare
yourself for an entirely new stage of
your career in a matter of months.
We can't wait to see where
your Nanodegree takes you.